- The other guy across the street.
Both of his brothers got killed.
One of them got gunned
down in a gas station
that I used to run with.
They gun him down.
And it's funny because, we just left him.
And he went to the gas station to get gas.
And his name was Donald.
And then his other brother
which is a older guy,
he get killed.
The older he thought his big brother,
and he's all I got left,
he's basically like family to me
from the same neighborhood I am.
We always had one another growing up
and, I go over there and I talk to him.
And, everyday I fear.
Because, the gang thing
it's like when you try to get out of it,
some gangs you ran through for life, man.
And you have the young kids, you know,
that's coming up and it's
way totally different
than with what it was when
we was in gangs and stuff.
You know, getting initiated,
see, we had a lot of deaths,
all through the seventies
and the nineties.
All I did, I went to more
funerals than I did, parties.
Then I had to bury my own brother.
And today it's like,
I walk around and I see gang members.
I find myself getting in the middle of
conversations with them.
It's like, you know to save guys,
'cause it's like today, I'll see you,
tomorrow, you ain't even here.
And it happens that quick, even down here.
And it's just like,
what happened to, the limits?
The boundaries, what happened to the guys
that's supposed to be
looking over us, man.
And these kids, man you know.
God let this happen to this kid.
And you know like,
when I was coming up to get in the gang,
you have to take a ass whooping.
Excuse my language, but you
gotta take a ass whooping.
And you have to prove yourself.
That's the way it really was,
and you have to be loyal.
You can't lie, if they found that,
if you went into prison and said,
"Well, look man, on the
street I was doing this,
I was doing that, I got a 65 Chevy."
You get took down for lying.
You know they stay loyal to the gang.
If you did something
bad, anything that you do
is gon' catch you and bite you in the ass.
Kids end up in prison with release dates.
Like today is 2020, their
release date is 2069.
These are young kids.
For gang-banging.
Just took a pop-shot at a somebody
that could have been their best friend.
2069,
3016,
these are EPRDs, which means,
this is the earliest possible
release date you can get out.
When I started going to prison in my days,
it was, they already told me,
there's only three ways Commodore
that you can get up outta here.
Wise, a homosexual or in
the box, it's your choice.
Believe me, a lot of guys
turned into three Nate.
I tell these guys now, if
they can see the future,
is so many opportunities,
out here on the street now.
And I wish I can even go back.
Even though I have my freedom.
But I still don't have the
pride that I used to have.
I still fear things, that
when I walk, it's like,
somebody called my name, "Hey, Commodore."
You think they ready to get
at your program, you know.
It's-
opportunities out here, man.
It's like-
if I had it my way, man, I'm telling you,
I could save some things, I
can help some people, you know.
So I just only tell
people, you know what man,
before you die, even my own friends,
'cause you can see it coming.
Tell young guys, alright man
so if they don't wanna listen,
just get to do yourself
a favor and get saved.
You know, hopefully
you might go to heaven.
You know, there's guys
walking around right now,
and then they don't like the OGs.
They figured they can get
strikes by knocking the OGs down.
There's gangs, turning on gangs.
Gangs fighting one another
like my gang, you know.
Originally, I'm originally
from Lueders Park.
I'm 58 years old today, thank God.
And if y'all can hear this,
you know I'mma tell y'all
I just like this man,
ain't no man hurting in no gang,
get in a grill gang, a church gang,
get in an organization that's
helping others, you know.
That shit is old, man.
The cemetery is overcrowded.
Just from
to 86 one cemetery,
one funeral home,
3060 something deaths.
And that was just all
gang related, you know.
It's just a lot of sadness going around.
It's just like the love
been stripped from people.
Don't understand them.
They ain't even in youngsters
heart like it used to be.
But I'mma tell you just like this though.
Being buff, selling weed,
selling dope, being young.
It ain't cool, man.
It's just so many opportunities.
There's so much to do out there man.
And I would tell all the youngsters man,
young girls man, I see
the fights down here.
Every day, we break 'em up.
You know, they really
wanna kill one another.
We lost a few youngsters
around the corner.
Guy get shot in the bag by a girl.
A lady shot him, killed him.
You know, serious.
This is not the life you want.
Because once you go to prison, man,
that's your wake up call.
The cold thing about it,
y'all not getting out.
We had a chance.
So take the opportunity today, man.
And do what you have to do, man.
Any loan.
I see you. I see you.
If you come downtown, I'm gonna see you.
I'mma run your ass up outta here.
You know, I don't even wanna be here.
This is not the life that you want.
You know, maybe a low rider.
You know, you take a little ride every now
and then I like shit, be still.
You know, ain't nothing
wrong with styling.
wrong with being a GQ.
But if you're watching this though, man,
that gang sign shit, it
ain't even gone work.
There was a guy,
I could tell you a young
man that got killed.
And he was mute.
He was only commuting to a guy,
communicating to another
guy across the street.
Doing his hands.
And somebody misconstrued that
and thought he was throwing up gang signs.
Cause he did his fingers the wrong way.
And this little kid got shot.
And he was only communicating
with his friend across the street.
Telling him to come get him.
You know, it's just, it's crazy.
And that's just not the
life that I wanna live.
This is not nothing I want to live.
So if I can give back,
I like to take this opportunity, man.
I go around, I talk to people.
I help people. I try to give back
because I don't want
God to be ashamed of me.
I want to be somebody in my life.
I ain't going to be here
much longer, you know but,
I'mma enjoy my moments, man.
I'mma enjoy trying to speak
to people, encourage them.
At least I can say I did mine
before it's all over with.
You know, I grew up.
It's just so messed up in gangs, man.
I went to drugs, you know I-
To get high let's go
shoot somebody, you know.
And this is,
let's go fight somebody
and be surprised, man.
Dynamite come in small package just too.
I had a good record.
Weight lifting 153 pounds,
bench pressing 440,
maxing it out, you know.
So that just even pumped my ego
won't be even bigger, you know.
Guys would try to get at me.
I mean, I had that punch that
it just sets you down but,
it ain't nothing to
brag about though, man.
If I can take things back, man
it'd be a lot of people still living.
If I wouldn't have did the dumbest shit,
it would have been a lot
of people still living.
If I hadn't turned my
back on a lot of people,
they'd still be living.
When people would say
reaching out helped me,
looking for that encouragement,
I didn't even comprehend that at the time.
They will still be living.
You know,
I'm telling you this, this not easy, man.
It's just woke up on you, you know.
And it's just, it's a lot of young people.
The schools is basically empty.
I wish I had opportunities.
Like we do go to trade, takes get paid.
Just get to go to school, man.
Just to learn some teaching,
then master something better
than what you're doing,
you know.
And care less about a gang, man.
It was cool when you was in it.
But telling you, man, when
you get behind a gun man,
and shoot somebody, that
experience is not what you want.
You know, to shoot, take somebody's life.
It's not what you want.
You know, we do what we do, but it's,
that's not what's happening.
That's not so going on
man, make mama proud.
Make yourself proud, do
something with your life.
You know, have a life man.
Said I'm trying to get
mine back, you know.
I did get my high school diploma.
So do yourself, apply get your GED
or get a high school diploma, man.
Get educated, man.
Be smart, man. Be smart man.
Cause y'all the next
people to take over, man.
Give us a better way, man.
I don't want nobody whooping
my ass in a convalescent home.
That shit is gonna get old in me.
(laughs)
I'm gonna be old in a minute.
I ain't going to becoming
on your door no more.
I'm gonna be that man
that y'all thought about,
Oh, this dude used to beat men, nah.
I still wanna be, when that time come.
I wanna go out happy, you know.
I wanna make my sister know, you know.
Somebody to tell me,
they was looking at this.
And they seen me and they say.
Commodore, we like what you said.
And they know I'm a freak
the truth. I'mma be real.
It makes me be proud of something,
and then motivates me to keep going.
To keep going, be make them listen,
make the ladies listen, man.
I had so many phone calls
then, now my ego is up
and you know, Commodore is back.
But I'm back in a positive way
to tell y'all something, man.
You know what, said ain't
no light in no darkness.
It ain't no such thing.
It's no such thing as,
I'mma sell a gang, a
dope, I'm a gang-bang man.
And I said, well next
year I'm gonna do that.
Ain't no such thing as next year.
It ain't none of that shit.
You know, the prisons love you.
They love people that
don't even think, you know.
Write yourself a letter, write
yourself a letter to yourself
and write yourself a letter
to that man upstairs.
They're thinking what you know
that he will tell you, his response.
And then you can see how
your attitude would be.
You'd be surprised what
come out your mouth.
And when you would come out your heart,
which you would really be
what you would really feel.
It's like, you don't have
to pay for your friendship.
I know how growing up can be.
I was little.
I felt the only hard, the
only way that I can fit in
I was paying for my friendship or health.
I was getting worked.
I'm the only one coming around,
spending money, buying beer, doing this.
Then they tried to introduce me to drugs.
Put a pipe in my mouth.
They owned me this is the
shit to do right here.
And they set a gun in your hand.
Next thing you know, man, I didn't.
I gave it a system over
30 years, you know.
And it's no fun in there.
Thank God I'm out here today.
So I would like to encourage people, man.
In myself every day.
So when I crawl out my bed
and touch my knees on the floor,
I'mma stay there for a minute.
I'mma thank God for another day.
And I'mma keep going, man.
I'mma just be ready for my day, man.
I'm just the type of person
that worry about my day.
That's what gang members do.
When we walk out the house, man,
we just tell God,
I hope don't let it happen to me today.
You know, because it's out
there, people recognize you.
You know that gang stuff
is not gon' get it.
It's not, I don't care where you from.
It's not gon' get it.
The war is still on, man.
But let's break that war down.
You know, let's do some
things that we need to do.
You know, if you're
young, come holla at me.
Holla at your boy, man.
I don't care where you from.
You know it, ain't no blood
coming up out of my mouth.
I knew where I'm originally from.
I made it.
I made it through the storm.
You know, storm was
just a big old screw up.
Believe me. But I held onto my nuts.
A lot of people lost theirs.
So you know, this shit is real.
That's all I can tell you,
man, it's really real, man.
I wish y'all the best.
I like to see people growing.
Cause we, waking up in the morning.
Watching people go to school and work.
That was motivate me.
It was just like that man
the won a lottery ticket.
You know, he just stood on his
balcony and just laugh, man.
Because when you get in your thirties
and you didn't did everything
you're supposed to do,
believe me you gon' have
every reason to smile.
Instead of waiting on a 30 pound bucks.
You know what I'm saying?
Somebody sent me a package
who gonna send me some money.
My girl's fucking this
dude, excuse my language.
But nah man, don't worry about that.
You know, take your time, get
educated, educate yourself.
Don't make the mistakes we did.
Don't make the mistakes my friends did.
Most of the people from us said,
they really stood loyal.
They stayed loyal to the game.
And I'mma tell you, I stay loyal to them.
If I had the hookup,
I would get in touch with a man
because that's where I come from.
I can't speak on other
sets, but where I come from.
You gotta be honest to the
game, not twisted, you know.
Are you gonna lose your life?
Even right now today I can lose mine.
My mind fully slip right down.
And I couldn't even
probably walk out this door.
And he goes just like this.
So yeah, I worry.
You know that tongue is a cold spot, man.
You can twist people up.
It can sink somebody ship
in a minute, you know.
I look back on the things that we did
and I look at how these
youngsters doing it.
They say sloppy, man.
Y'all don't need to do shit like this.
You know,
goes clamping a friend
doing go out the back.
Y'all don't need to do that.
But I'm telling you to prisons,
there's no place to be.
They got a lot of prison.
And it ain't like, they used to be.
They don't even feel like they used to be.
They don't even have weights.
You can't smoke a cigarette.
You know, only thing
you gon' do is stress.
And that one of them do, some
officers kill you up in there.
And they still gang-bang you in there.
Everything a kitchen.
But one thing led to five years,
you realize you're not getting out,
because your release date is 5,080.
You ain't never gon' get out.
And that's the type of
time they handing out.
One thing I could tell you,
my name is Commodore Romania.
I could just, I wish you all the best man.
Peace.